where the hell is the spider-man trailer
where's the spider-man 3 trailer
what the hell spider-man damn it nothing
anyway so uh it's december 26th john
just showed up how's
how are you john i'm okay merry
christmas merry christmas how was your
how was your christmas it was a it was a
pleasant very
uh loose day no all right that was yours
good good watch wonder woman 1984. spent
some time with the fam bam i had a nice
dinner with my fiance
it was good all the while stressing out
waking up at five
in the morning just keep checking my
phone is this spiderman trailer coming
out instead we got a one division one uh
from marvel instead and i did notice
on the trailer for the reality one for
one division on the comments there's a
lot of people going
where's the spider-man trailer where's
the spider-man trailer there's been so
many
so many of those comments and then i was
like you know what i'm gonna do some
research i want to talk about this
because i was like i don't this isn't
marvel's thing to deal with and i feel
like
within spider-man tom holland
specifically you start thinking like
this is
mrs marvel's but we often forget that
it's really
sony's sony's is the top dog when it
comes to the situation when it comes to
when this trailer is going to come out
it's all in the hands of sony so for
people to be going to marvel's page and
bitching at marvel like no no you're
bitching at the wrong youtube channel
you got to go to sony's right now no
seriously you do that i mean it's like
when you look at venom or morbius or
into the spider verse you automatically
go sony that's sony's
you know but for some reason with
spider-man because of the fact that he
is really
directly tied into the mcu we go marvel
you're responsible for this where's our
trailer
well everyone just wants marvel to take
him back entirely so i think they're
just putting that out into the
atmosphere
by doing that it's a consistent thing as
i've been doing some research there's
been some conflicting reports
but i think i have a pretty solid gauge
for when the trailer might actually come
out there's the event
uh the billy billy uh in china where
marvel kevin feige is going to be there
on new year's eve where he was teasing
how they're going to be possibly showing
some images or even footage perhaps uh
leading into 2021 of the marvel movies
and shows to come out so
maybe we'll get an eternals trailer
maybe we'll get some shang qi
footage you know it seems likely that we
might get something from there in terms
of footage-wise so then we'll stress out
about spending new year's eve away from
our loved ones just to cover trailers
we have to end the year strong yeah so
this event of billy billy i don't think
the trailer will be coming out there and
the reason being is because of the fact
of everything that we have
talked about with marvel and sony that
is a marvel
related event even at the disney
investor day we heard nothing about
spider-man and we know they're filming
it
we they've been filming it for the past
month there's all this casting reports
coming out
daniel richtman who is like there's the
two top scoopers are like mikey sutton
and daniel rickman
and daniel rickman talked about how they
don't think they would get a
teaser in store until toby maguire is
officially signed on
i'm under the impression that he already
is you know at the same time they've
only been shooting for a month i was
doubting that they would release a
trailer on christmas day because of the
fact that they've only been shooting for
a month and maybe a little bit longer
let's say they had time to like edit it
cut it together or whatever you still
have to like do proper cgi
and all these things i feel like at best
what they can give us before the end of
the year is at least an official title
reveal
i think we get excited about title
reveals for
movies like this one especially because
if it is something that implies
multiverse really does imply that even
though kevin feige has
stated at the disney investor day of how
like one division and doctor strange
multiverse and madness do tie in with
the events of spider-man so we already
know just you know that fun
fan confirmation of yes it really is
tying in but bottom line is that's gonna
be a very solely marvel based event
and i highly highly doubt sony's gonna
have a trailer in time by the new year's
eve and i just don't think
sony would want to release it at that
day would it be marvel because
it seems it seems like there's always
this battle of egos when it comes to
marvel and sony right
yeah and it seems like sony wants to
drive the biggest parts of the fan you
know excitement or whatever because you
know they came out with a black eye
either way regardless of the
circumstances from all the negotiations
and everything people
shouting at sony from every direction
and uh yeah i
also feel like they're probably very
aware of everyone's expectations and are
taking time to
have advantage over that i feel like
nowadays you have to be a little more
conscientious in those shoes with how
you put out your teaser footage because
release dates are soft right now and
especially a movie as
big as this new spider-man i don't think
they're gonna want to
you know blow their load too soon and
then have to push the movie back way far
or whatever
but i also think that yeah like the
stage in the game that we are a few
years
a few days off from new year's eve
something like a title confirmation and
maybe like the official
confirmation of the casting or something
might be
a fun way to celebrate that or something
they can still surprise us with and
maybe even having some kind of
video that's not a scene or anything but
just the three actors that we're all
waiting for
together confirming it revealing the
title somehow like that i could
see as being like a tree thinking like a
cool vibe like when tom holland revealed
the far from home title because i got a
script can't say anything but it's like
we all saw that said far from home some
fun
video like that tom holland and then in
the background there's tobey mcguire
yeah like oh damn guys get out of the
way yeah it's something like that where
it's like oh it didn't mean to spoil it
for you so here's what i'm thinking of
when the trailer
might come out because we have barely
heard anything about morbius
i think they're at like tokyo comic-con
or something if i'm not mistaken one of
those cons
overseas an un-american one if i'm not
mistaken
so they were there like jared leto was
there and then um you know we
we haven't heard anything really about
venom let there be carnage
morbius is still slated for 2021
uh spring if i'm mistaken and i think
they're gonna want to start driving up
their momentum with the vaccine coming
out right now it's like i have
family members one who already got the
vaccine another one who
is about to get the vaccine so it's
because of the line of work they live in
so the vaccine's being distributed and i
feel like that's going to make a big
difference because that does tie
into what we're gonna do with movie
theaters and if we're gonna start
releasing some of these movies in
theaters again
and so depending on the progress of that
if it does stick the landing to its
release date
sony's been really quiet about a lot of
their movies not like monster hunter did
them any favors you know
so i'm thinking that whenever for sure
morbius is officially coming out i feel
like we'll probably get our spider-man 3
trailer closer to then
we'll probably get it like leading into
when the the movie's going to come out
maybe they'll wait till the day the
movie comes out but
right around then is when i think
they're going to be doing it that way we
can start getting the
sony spider-verse hype train rolling all
over again because we'll get more beasts
and we'll get venom we'll get spider-man
3. i forget which the religion which one
comes first bottom line is
2021 could be the year for spider-verse
so i think they'd want to start
really building that momentum and hype
train rolling
by then so my prediction is right around
the time of morbius comes out and i feel
like we'll have time to
they're going to want to perfect this
trailer they can't have asked this one
yeah and i feel like they'll probably
maybe
also want to give us a more flesh look
at venom because i get the sense that
that's further along too so because
you've had these
big chunk event days like the disney
investor day
that had marvel included in that maybe
also sony might want to take an
opportunity to really
put their three spider-verse films
together in a big way and reveal them
all at the same time somehow
so as to gain some of that good will
back here i think
i think that's the proper time to expect
it but if something comes out before the
end of the year
i'm not gonna complain bring it my way
let's do it
guys when do you think this trailer will
come out are you a little bit irked with
sony and marvel
let's find out subscribe click that
notification bell we'll be sure to cover
any real updates that come out hot
scoops whatever hit that like button
happy new year mary
holidays you know what i'm trying to say
bye
you